on the big game on Sunday
80 million viewers are gonna watch two
teams Duke it out on the gridiron what
they don't know is that they're actually
watching a whole lot of physics as well
hi my name is Aneesa Ramirez welcome to
science explained I'm joining you from
the birthplace of American football Yale
University where Walter camp class of
1880 designed the game the way that we
know it football
it's full of physics when a quarterback
throws a bomb to a wide receiver in
stride
that's all physics in order for a
quarterback to connect with a wide
receiver he has to take into account two
things the shape of the ball and the
spin the shape of the ball is called a
prolate spheroid which is just a fancy
way to say that it's longer in one
direction than it is in the other it's
the shape that allows it to travel long
distances without any air resistance if
I were to turn the ball sideways and
throw the ball this way it wouldn't go
very far because there's a lot of area
for the air to push against it and it
wouldn't travel very far there'd be lots
of drag however if the ball's facing in
this direction it can slice through the
air there's less drag and it can travel
even further distances the quarterback
also applies a spin to the ball when we
spin the ball the ball acts like a
gyroscope and it's able to hit its
target with much more precision also the
spinning of the ball allows for less air
resistance or less drag so they can
travel to its destination even more
quickly so you see there's lots of
physics the quarterback can apply spins
on the order of six hundred revolutions
per minute that's as fast as a CD
playing inside of your CD player that's
pretty fast so concepts that you've
heard before such a spin and drag we all
use these on the gridiron football is
more than the battle of wills it's the
battle of who uses physics the best I'm
a nice ramirez thanks for joining us at
science explained and I hope that you'll
join us for another edition